là
voilà voilà
connolly blessé par le chien sorti c'est
monsieur seros à la télévision qu'est ce
que c'est
c'est 30 millions d'amis ça vient d'un
rendez-vous que michel serrault il est
là non monsieur n'est pas là mais nous y
sommes mais commençait pas vous y fier
c'est moi c'est ma fac d'ailleurs qu'à
ses toxines
à cette heure-ci oui je suis obligé de
le manque de personnel je m'occupe de la
maison et je ne peux pas vous recevoir
en tant que a bondi de dorian a lancé
pour là on s'est trompé non mais
simplement
c'est pourquoi écouter en faire un film
sur michel serrault et 30 millions
d'amis vous savez ces animaux et cetera
voulait voir les animaux y le faux voilà
donc vous êtes combien ans les quatre
mais n'oubliez pas méchant vous avez
mangé
non parce que je vous dis parce que
quelquefois quand on vient chez moi
on vient les journées j'enlève les jours
de l'arrivée de manger de boire et de
manger et des quelques fois même de
casser
alors est ce que vous avez mangé déjà
nous on a mangé il avait vu manger
oui donc pour la casse l'addition va 100
ça fait vous allez rentrer doucement
simplement je vous demanderai de faire
très attention parce que effectivement
nous avons deux années les fonds axés
support je ne peux pas reprocher parce
que je ne peux pas les normes briand qui
est très oui vindicatif année le réseau
sagir aucune aucune réflexion devant le
chien me concernant ah bon parce qu'il
est ni peut-être contre les
surinfections
d'accord je prends ma femme ma fille
naîtra le personnel de la maison tout ça
vous pouvez dire ce que vous voulez mais
sur moi nous dit ni les uns et les
autres mais monsieur ne fait pas de
genre de réflexion déplaisante car vous
seriez mon dû répondre directement suite
on rirait s'il vous plaît messieurs
allons-y excusez moi voyez jeu parce que
j'ai des heures et des heures où sont
obligés de m'occuper de la maison entre
et non pour rester
enfin bon double voie de personnel
ensemble et non qu'est ce que ça vous ne
vous vous êtes photographe me suis
rentré vous êtes avant vous êtes un
médecin local il veut s'en rendraient
monsieur excusez moi votre venue pardon
je ferme c'est terminé c'est terminé
c'est complet pour le moment s'il vous
plaît
attention ça glisse énormément de neige
nous devons ici jusqu'à un mètre
quatre-vingt dave séjour citoyens et
c'est dans cette uniquement que cette
cette portion de neuilly on sait pas ce
qu'il ya une part ici mes premiers avec
le bon dieu non alors simplement je vous
demanderais les plus dans les têtes de
ben non non les enfants d'abord parce
qu'il fait pas de mordant au fond du
tout les enfants vous avez déjà des
enfants par mais vous ne compterez très
bien ce que le visage leur ferons du
mieux donc
alors si vous voulez mon attention
voilà je me dit regarde
oui alors michel serrault ya un cerbère
terrible qui nous a fait un barrage à la
mesure je vous avez vous avez promis
nous élever mon valet de chambre
oui oui message remarqué là je suis là
vous risquez rien mais en principe alors
il ya de personnes sont pas faciles mais
dans cette série d'un chien et le chien
mais le chien
présentez-nous le candidat écoutez vous
voulez vous retournez d'abord essayé
vous s'il vous plaît assez vous servez
le schuss à peine voilà un peu de poil
mais ce soir on a l'habitude alors
assieds toi c'est toi mais tu vois pas
rester voilà bon jour là vous auriez dû
vous mettre de l'autre côté parce que
est bon c'est romulus à chaque et qui
est avec nous depuis dix ans quand même
c'est votre copain vous l'aimez bien
or by fait partie de la famille
évidemment mais parce que ces cas est un
peu curieux c'est que ont l'habitude
d'aller tourner chez les acteurs ils ont
un côté copa america je vais vous
demander la permission est ce que je
peux enlever cette trempe de chant à
écouter jouer parce que quand même plus
détendu parce que je voulais vous faire
plaisir dit que ça serait mieux avec de
la couleur de me sens un peu guindée
mais en lui il va pas changer d'europe
évidemment
voilà c'est vrai puisqu'on peut pas et
au théâtre toute la journée
voilà une hache-- soir voilà oui alors
dites moi ce qui m'étonne beaucoup c'est
que ce chien et il ya un chat aussi dans
la maison et on a vraiment l'impression
ce sont des membres de la famille oui
bien sûr steria qui vivent avec nous ils
ont tout le temps là ils sont pas des
enfants quand même sur des bêtes même ça
reste des bêtes non mais enfin vous
dites à votre est-ce que le chien est là
je veux dire comme un peu comme on dit
est ce que margaret et rentrèrent oui
c'est ça est ce que oui armées russes a
fait ses devoirs
est-ce qu'il a bien mangé ce qui va bien
oui michel serrault qu'est-ce-qui qu'est
ce qui vous intéresse dans les gros
chiens vous aimez les gros chiens moi
peur personnellement j'aime bien la
présence d'un groupe d'un gros chien je
trouve que ça web et dans la maison par
exemple sans payer de temps etc
non ça vous au pourquoi vous savez ça
nous ça c'est comme les noms je trouve
que la présence d'un gros chien d'abord
paul à la sécurité si vous voulez là et
puis ça a l'air d'un chien j'aime bien
des bêtes qui sont pas trop trafiqué
parce qu'ils étaient des chiens on sait
plus très bien ce que c'est oui c'est
une machine à cause d'un choix
chapeau 2 avec des fleurs on ne sait pas
très bien je veux dire par là on arrive
à une telle sélection je trouve que et
de fabrication c'est un peu comme les
rôles alors je sais qu'on fait très
belle rose mais enfin le trafic un peu
trop les chiens d'eau qu'un chien
robuste vous avez le cher pour moi c'est
un peu comme la cuisine j'aime les plats
est arrivé est solide
oui mais net qui sont pas trop
sophistiqués alors les gros chiens au
général et par exemple celui ci il
adéquat dans la maison qu'il intéresse
pas ou que vous savez où vous devriez
pas posé cette question demandait de
vendée lui je crois que c'est la cuisine
d'ailleurs si vous regardez quand vous
arrivez ils vous regardent à la fenêtre
enfin oui mais actuellement ils guettent
web et et alors et c'est évidemment ils
voulaient porte aussi le fait d'être
chaud et brive pour les parents et amis
les magnifiques non ce qu'il faut alors
il lâcha simplement il a un petit défaut
ça je dois le dire d'abord c'est un
chien de garde formidable ça c'est pas
des faux mails un défaut de ces je parle
doucement parce qu'une toujours
l'impression qu'ils temps en temps ils
vont regarder dans les yeux milan mais
il comprend très bien il va peut-être
baisser la tête
est-ce que tu voles est-ce que vous
volez romulus ben oui ils chabrat alors
l'intérêt de l'année 2010 de beurre pour
le 3 state comme une chose
extraordinaire jeudi reçues le chien à 1
m la journée will maîtresse le soir
enfin sur veut dire oui à voir vous
voulez parler du théâtre
oui oui bah oui mais ne connaît pas sous
cet angle là ouais il a rarement vu en
robe même à la télévision et je ne me
fierais pas parce qu'ils seraient
capables de mort tu sais ce que c'est
ton personnage c'est ce père inconnu
superbe dans la démarche
et puis tout à coup il se trouve dans
cette chose incroyable cette apparition
tu crois que tu la regardes et tu
ressens comme une espèce étape
essentielle qui que lectrice
délicieusement quand je passe si je
passe dans la cage aux folles dans un
extrait de la cage aux folles achevant
là il va être très surpris parce qu'il
est peut-être reconnaître la voix
autrement il est très bon spectateurs
tous les soirs depuis cinq ans pour
michel serrault c'est le même rituel 18
sans représentation de la cage aux
folles
après un maquillage compliqué une demi
heure plus tard
la métamorphose est réussi un personnage
en vie excessif et haut en couleur
parlez nous un peu de chaleur c'est un
choix extrêmement distance des heureux
il est très bien élevé il faut pas
l'ennuyer
il vous dit bonjour quand il en a envie
mais il est très mignon c'est une
chantal elle est très mignonne elle est
très belle et puis j'aime bien parce que
l mangeant le sait se tenir à table je
veux dire très vite ipad fanion non mais
non seulement elles ne doivent pas mais
je vous hais elle lui jeu ça m'embête de
dire ça devant lui mais il veut aurait
tendance est un peu fruste équipe le
goinfre enfin je vous dirais même bien
elle n'ose pas quand elle a pris un peu
de foi peu de poisson il faut le sentir
on peut la sortir il est d'ailleurs
allen ligne magnifique vous la verrez
quand même j'espère avant le départ on
va l'avoir viré je voudrais pas te
retrouvera en parler de parler de
caramel puisque c'est le nom de la
châtelain devant mais parce qu'il peut
prendre ombrage et n'empêche que je
rentre tous les soirs d'un après les en
général je ne dénie pas avant de jouer
donc je vous dise tous les soirs vers
une heure du matin d'hudson je suis seul
je suis sûr que non heureusement j'ai
mon chien et ma chatte
sinon pour vous serez va redécouvrir aux
femmes sont en face de mon camembert
parce que facebook
mais voilà oui secondes
oui madame monsieur qu'elle est d'ordre
dans toute la france ont aucune chanteur
qui tout secondes vous permettez oui
enfin que la jante lourds à moteur mais
pas aimé ça que tu veux
vous aurez des fromages tout allumage
tout à l'heure vous laissera les croûtes
comme d'habitude quoi gecas bien une
seconde on s'occupe de vous aussi à 10
ans leur attaque est vraiment chose pour
vous oui voilà voilà alors elle a rien
du tout voilà la mouteyre vous ça vous
intéresse pas il n'y a plus rien à rien
c'est terminé a dit don bombe à ceux ci
d'après lui on n'est pas plus que ça à
faire un peu de repos pour tout le monde
oui mais